foreign
Legion yes Legion you so you just to
clarify your name used to be
my name used to be
Tia Matt Medusa the dragon lady that's
what I used to go by from so many years
but recently I have uh and gone through
another stage of my transformation of my
metamorphosis
and that is to
become the final product the the dragon
that I'm aiming to be so it requires me
to shed certain different things in my
life uh along the way like I had
mentioned before there are certain
things that I don't eat anymore
um I my my hearings changed because of
my mods because you cut off your ears
yeah
can you repeat that please
um but the name legion basically uh is
for a way for me to simplify with my
friends and my family uh
um what what what my name is because
everybody was like you got all these
names we know and I'm like yes I know
what was your name what was your given
name when you were born my birth name
was Richard
Hernandez
and just two days ago I went to the DMV
here in Los Angeles
um and I got my name changed because the
court had already approved it for me
when I applied for uh petitions for my
name so what does your driver's license
say
Tiamat Legend Medusa
wow that is my final name but I'm only
going by the name legion because for
some reason the name legion is easy for
everybody to to pronounce plus everybody
knows about Legion some people get
scared like oh my God why did you pick
that name that's a scary name that's a
bad name that's a bad name oh you're the
legion from the Bible I'm like yes I am
so you've had so much body modification
let's let's give me a little list of
what you've done you have
your eyes are the whites of your eyes
are green bright green I've had my eyes
tattooed green the green eyes of Medusa
or the Dragon
um I have had both my ears removed
because serpents don't have ears and I'm
a serpent dragon you also had your nose
flattened is that right I had my nose
yes modified
um basically I when I first saw Harry
Potter and I saw Lord Voldemort
uh as one of the characters in that show
I immediately became in love I love the
Lord Voldemort I want to marry Lord
Voldemort we would make such a great
couple but uh so
um and this is in honor of Lord
Voldemort I got my nose modified to look
like his
and also and also to be like a reptile
yes yes
it served two purposes it was part of my
my reptilian metamorphosis becoming a
reptile I had to get rid of my human
nose because reptiles have a flat nose
you know don't have nose they just kind
of too little that's what I have two
little holes on each side
of my
whatever's left of whatever knows there
those two little holes are where I
breathe and I can no longer scratch my
nose like people and you put your finger
and scratch your nose and there's
certain things I can't do anymore but
it's okay I like learning to live
than on you
your goal is to become a a a you said
last time a genderless genderless dragon
that is my goal that is my ultimate goal
yes I have had my tongue split
you sure have I've had most of my teeth
removed I am going to be continuing that
process until all of my teeth are out of
my mouth and that's a new development in
my in my metamorphosis I was initially
evolving or transforming myself to
become a
the image of of a rattlesnake but it's
because rattlesnakes have teeth a
rattlesnake it's rattlesnakes are near
and dear to my heart simply because uh
when I was abandoned by my mother and
and my stepdad at the age of four left
out in the middle of the woods they left
us there in the middle of a a
rattlesnake rattlesnake country
and so I adopted the rattlesnake as as
my parents when my parents tossed me out
of the car and didn't want me your
parents abandoned you for what reason
it was basically all
the reason my parents abandoned me is uh
has everything to do with my stepfather
demand that my mother chose to hook up
with after she left my father
and uh and brought she had four kids she
was like 21 years old and she had four
kids
so it was rough for her things were
rough for her and I I realized that and
you know the fact that I was abandoned
uh I don't really hate my mother I don't
Harbor any ill will or resentment
against her I love my mother regardless
of everything that has happened
regardless of her decision to push me
out of the car and say y'all y'all need
to stay there while she was crying in
through tears I can still hear see her
tears and her crying because she was
doing something that was very hard for
her to do
um
I always felt sorry for my mother
because I always took him into
consideration not only the time
uh this was back in the 1960s when
things were like really really bad uh in
the world it was very taboo to be gay I
mean just being gay could could get you
killed back in the 60s and and the 70s
as well especially in Texas where you
grew up oh my God yeah Texas where I
grew up and then I grew up in South
Texas uh where it's the spirit of male
machismo is alive and well and that's
always bothered me this male machismo
attitude that you know pervaded
the the entire area where I grew up so I
grew up around that and it was you grew
up in a very small town right I grew up
in a really small town
um the town that I grew up in had only
like 350 people total population
and it's basically pretty much stayed
that way over the last 50 years since
I've been gone
so back to your modifications I I we got
off track there you also have horns yeah
I have horns on my head I have 18 horns
on my head I have more horns on my head
than anyone else in the world
and and I'm going for my first world
record official world record with
Guinness for the person with the most
horns
so
um that's something that I'm working on
right now and it's it's coming around
the band and plenty of tattoos
yeah my uh uh my tattoo is also one of
my modifications I'm working on a full
body
Dragon Tattoo serpent dragon tattoo so
I've got serpent scales tattooed
throughout most of my body which is
pretty much mostly outlined I do have
some of the work complete like this
sleeve the right sleeve is finished
uh no not finished the the left sleeve
is finished but it's going to be redone
and and so is the right one
um
and we're talking about the dragon
Legion and you know and the name legion
I think this is very important for me to
make sure and to clarify that that is my
name first of all it's my legal name
it's my legal middle name so yeah I love
that name I'm proud of it I love the
name legion I've always loved it ever
since the first time I heard of Legion
in the Bible
so
um the fact that
um
that some people say well why did you
choose that name it's scary what is the
what is the origin of legion
well
um
you know the way my my story relates to
the story of Legion is basically uh when
when Legion says my name is Legion for
we are many
well if you look back at my
transformation
back to where I was before I even
started
I had I I am known by different names
by different people
who have followed my transformation and
so they they're aware that I used to be
Richard and then I used to be
no man I used to be pan I used to be Eva
um
all these names are
in a way personas of me and they're you
know I've heard people say she has a
multiple personality disorder
and I'm thinking no I have all my
personalities in order
and they're quite well and I love them
all I don't deny any of them
I am all the people that people have
known me by
so I chose the name legion to make it
easy for people just as a way for me to
say since people you know different
people know me under as different names
I'm going to make it easy for everybody
and just call me Legion because that is
all of my names including Tiamat
including Medusa those are all combined
into my middle name which is Legion so
Legion is
even though it's a middle name to me
it's probably
more important
than the name Tiamat and the T and the
name Medusa
so um that's just a little explanation
of the name legion and also
because people have gotten used to
seeing me the way I look they have a
certain look that's my look it was the
dragon ladies look but the Dragon Lady
is no longer I I'm doing away with
gender
um so your goal is not to be a female or
not to be this isn't a sexual thing at
all right it's not a sexual thing at all
I don't want to be referred to as
anything having to do with gender
because I reject both genders I'm not
you know
um I don't claim to be a man or a woman
I I defy you still you still have your
male genitalia I have my penis um I was
a I one of the body modifications that I
did get was to have an orchiectomy which
is a castration procedure I got that
done in 2018.
um so all that's left is Mr Bojangles Mr
Bojangles won't go away he keeps hanging
in there it's time for him to go chat
be gone bye-bye Mr Bojangles
yeah no yeah Mr Bojangles is my penis
that's his name and that's coming off
one day
so tell me like something happened to
you as a young man that maybe steered
the direction of your life I remember
you told me about this in the last
interview which was a shorter one
well my life has been riddled ever since
I was a kid with hardships and um
a lot of trials and tribulations uh some
good times I do have some fun memories
of my childhood but they're few and far
between honestly and I spent the entire
time that uh the entire
time that I was
either like in grade school and all the
way through High School
all that period the all that all those
years of my life I would just wanted to
die
I hated my life I hated my grandfather
who had raised me as his own and adopted
me my mother's father
so my my paternal my maternal
grandparents took me in to raise as as
their own but my troubles didn't end
there they continued because I was a
spitting image of my father of Richard
Hernandez senior I was a junior
and that was like uh taboo you know to
have to even speak his name under the
roof of the house where I lived uh so I
I I I I I I suffered a lot of ridicule a
lot of scorn a lot of uh criticism
um because I was named after my father
and I was basically a spitting image of
him I looked like his twin
so I was definitely a Richard Hernandez
Jr
but you know I tell people
being named after somebody should be
something very special
and it should have been an honor and a
privilege for me to have been named
after my father
and it wasn't
to me was a curse because
I heard
things like you're never going to amount
to anything you're going to be just like
your father worthless nobody's gonna
want you you're good for nothing look at
you you're just like your father I I
heard those words
repeatedly over so many years during the
time when I needed to hear words of
inspiration words of support show of
support and love from those people that
should have loved me which were my
grandparents
and my grandmother did love me but my
grandfather
was a totally different Beast
um he was very homophobic and I for one
was never in the closet I came out very
early in my lifetime and I told
everybody in school and uh anyone that I
would meet in the town I would let
everybody know hey I am gay
does it surprise anyone no because you
are already calling me Hawthorne queer
and marigon and all these names I'm
grabbing my ass all right I went through
a lot of that in in school I had guys
would uh grab my ass just because
um it was their way of
and
I guess expressing or showing power over
me because they were the male machismo
type yet
I was gay and
they would
be up on me that they would pick on me
and Bully me and I for one
Never back down I didn't care how big a
bully was to me I saw a bully as a bully
a bully is a bully is a bully no matter
how big they are how small they are what
nationality they are what story they
have a bully is a bully and they're
going to do what bullies do so what I
did is I stood up to those bullies I
sure did I got into a couple of fist
fights and guess what I didn't lose any
of them
because I'm not scared to get right down
yeah I hang from hooks I do I do hook
suspensions where I hang from hooks in
my body and the the most hooks I've had
in my body at one time when I do the
suspension was 50 hooks I was suspended
up in the air
through 50 hooks in my you know going
through my flesh so getting into a fist
fight with someone for me like oh you
bring it you know that that's like you
know
Showdown let's go see let's see what you
know let's see what you got because I
know what I got and I ain't scared of
you bully I'm not scared of you you can
call me names you can throw things at me
you can chase me down the street just
don't touch me or get near enough to me
where I can touch you because
you're gonna like what's gonna happen
I will defend myself against a bully I
will fight someone if I have to
but
if I can walk away from a fight I always
choose to do that first but when you
know there are some people who they're
just plain mean and ugly and nasty I've
had a lot of those kind of people
approach me here in skid row it hasn't
been easy and just a a joy ride in the
park for me to live in Skid Row this is
the second time that I've been here and
the first time was absolutely scary I
did not realize Skid Row existed I
didn't know what it was about all I know
is that I was tossed into skid row and
said there you go fend for yourself what
do you choose to live in Skid Row
the reason I chose Skid Row is because
when I came to California because drugs
are not your thing no no no I don't do
drugs
um I don't do drugs a lot of people
automatically assume incorrectly that
I do drugs
I've had so many people ask me hey do
you are you looking for Crystal are you
looking for Molly are you looking for
like no I ain't looking for nothing I
ain't looking for no one I got my weed
here in my hand why do you choose to
live on Skid Row
well the reason I I live in Skid Row is
because when I came to California I I
didn't realize I was going to end up
homeless on the streets and that's what
happened I ended up homeless on the
street and being that I'm I was I was a
transgender person
um and being extremely modified I'm like
an easy target for people so it was
important to get me off the street and
into a shelter as quickly as possible so
that's how I ended up being in Skid Row
I needed to a place to live and the
shelter was uh one the shelter that I
went to uh accepted me and then they
placed me into an apartment so I'm
basically going through that same
process again today where I'm looking at
being placed in my own apartment uh next
week and uh
I'd be having my own my own apartment
and out of the shelter but
um
Skid Row is is is really interesting
because I have met so many wonderful
wonderful people here honestly and then
I have met some really really bad people
too so there's there's mix it's like a
Melting Pot
um of different people different
personalities people come from all walks
of life from all over the country from
different parts of the world they come
to skid row because a lot of people
honestly come to skid row because it's
an easy Haven for them to do their drugs
um and I'm not judging because I used to
do drugs long long time ago 20 years ago
I did drugs so I'm not going to sit here
and point the finger at anyone who does
drugs today I just stay away from them
we're not if I know someone does drugs
no I don't hate on them I'm not going to
put them down I'm just like later
bye have you always been a uh a
non-conformist I mean like your whole
Persona is is gonna raise eyebrows
everywhere you go yes yes I have always
been a non-conformist where does that
come from I
you know
I do card readings and I do my own daily
uh affirmation I have one a daily card
affirmations that that I read to just
just kind of see where things are for me
in my life and uh one of the the
messages that I got from my cards was
that I needed to look to and uh embrace
and really
trust my
inner gut instincts my instincts
my inner self my inner worth you know so
I think that's basically where it comes
from but
it it
the strength that I have
to live in the world that would be so
critical of me and so ugly to me and
people have been really ugly towards me
um
all of that
all of those experiences all the people
that have tried to hurt me and those two
who have hurt me
uh uh I'm I'm just over here saying
I'm still here I'm still standing you
knocked me down but you didn't get keep
me down nothing keeps me down and I
think that is where my strength comes
from Mark it comes from within myself
uh ever since I was like four years old
I was uh abused by my uh um stepfather
and then the abuse continued with my
grandfather on my life all through my
teen years all through high school until
finally I graduated from high school and
I said I am so out of here because this
isn't working for me this environment
which is supposed to be my home
is it working for me because my
grandfather and I were always at odds
and we were I was fighting
and I told my grandfather one day I said
you know what
I said we're supposed to love one
another you're supposed to love me
because I'm your son
and I'm supposed to love you because
you're my father
I said but we don't get along and we
haven't in a long time and I don't know
if things will ever change
so the only thing that I can do that I
can think of to rectify the situation
is to move to step away to get out
if I I'm that kind of person if I get an
Inkling
if someone gives me just the suggestion
of you're not wanted here
I'm gone you don't tell me twice I don't
need to be there because I know that I
don't need to be in that situation
so my my strength
comes from within
the test of my medal of what I'm made of
comes to me in different forms sometimes
I'm tested on on social media where
people uh test my my medal and you know
my resolve you know my inner strength
they put me to the test and challenged
me by by putting me on the offense
but instead of going on the offense with
people
most of the times I just choose to walk
to walk away because in in in in in in
the real world of snakes
a lot of people think oh my God she's a
snake snakes are scary and rattlesnakes
are scary they're evil they're bad no
they're not they're just a snake you
know they want to have their own
property which is their natural habitat
and then you come and you destroy their
natural habitat and then you wonder why
you got snakes in your backyard well
guess what that used to be the
rattlesnake's backyard and you stole
their backyard away from them and now
you complaining because they're there
so I people are weird about snakes and
honestly I've been around snakes all my
life I've handled so many different
snakes not one time not one time in my
entire 62 years of life
yes I'm 62. not one time has a reptile
of any kind ever ever hurt me
never
on the other hand
it's just a totally different picture
when I paint the picture of humanity
humans
have hurt me
so many times
needlessly
yeah on purpose
taking advantage of my kindness because
I'm a kind and gentle person
and mistaking my making my meekness for
weakness
don't mistake my meekness for weakness
because if you summon the in me
guess what you're going to get
the in me
she is one of my personalities and her
name is Tiamat
so you you come after me you come after
tmat TMS going to get up and she's going
to Scorch your eyebrows first and then
she's going to burn your ass
you mentioned abuse as a child from your
from your dad or stepdad
my stepfather
hated me because I was named after my
father here again here again goes the
story of my father's name and why I say
that being named after my father instead
of it being a wonderful thing oh man I
was named after my dad I was named after
my father I'm so proud
and I was
I was proud to be named after my dad
because I loved my dad
and I wish my mother had not left him
but she did
so her decisions affected me and my my
siblings because we no longer had a dad
um so I grew up without a dad but my
stepfather had an opportunity to be
a dad to be a father figure for me
and all he did was abuse me and hurt me
he would abuse me emotionally
psychologically and physically
I was I was barely in the first grade
that there was also abuse when you were
like in your late teens
when you left home when I left home at
the age of 19 of 18 rather
um I I
I know it sounds crazy but this is what
happened I left home
got because I needed to get out of that
situation that was so toxic with my
grandfather and I came to I went to
Houston to live with my mother and my
stepfather of all people
and
it's not not surprisingly but
it just didn't work out I think I
actually stayed with them
probably a couple of months
before I needed I felt like I needed to
just get away from that situation
because it was very toxic and very bad
for me and my my stepfather
this is how he would talk and I'm going
to mock him to just talk the way he does
he used to tell me when I was just a
little kid I was just in the first grade
now first grade
he used to say Reiki
he I hated for him to call me that
Ricky he would say we need to go hunting
you and me I have a gun
I'm thinking okay I'm in the first grade
and you have a gun which is not a
hunting gun by the way it's a pistol
you don't use a pistol to go hunt
rabbits and javelinas
you used a pistol to shoot somebody I
knew that even as a kid I knew that so I
I felt from the very beginning uh very
early on that he was up to no good when
it came to me and he was out
to do away with me
he encouraged my mother to call aunts
and uncles family members
uh asking the family members to take one
of the kids
so she had four kids from my father
so they needed a home for four kids
that they didn't want
my mother and my stepfather they were
trying to home us to Foster us out
and the family all came back and said
well we would love to take one but we
don't want to separate them there were
because there were three of us that were
left behind
um our little baby sister was too young
so they didn't leave her behind even my
mother and my stepdad took her so they
already separated us from one of our
siblings
and the other family members were like
no well we love y'all and we love them
and we would love to take one of the
kids but we're not going to separate
them and we don't we can't take three
kids so nobody could nobody had a home
for us
nobody was able to take us and that is
what caused my stepfather and my mother
to come up with an idea with with the
scheme to leave us with my grandparents
by force basically which meant they were
going to just abandon us
and they did
have you been in love before
yes I've known love I've known love I I
had a partner of 20 years
um he was the love of my life his name
was Mark
so yeah
um I do know I have no love he was Mark
was the first person that ever showed me
what it was like to be loved
to be cared for to be considered
to be thought of as good
and to be shown
that I am worthy of being loved I never
felt that my entire life
from my family
because of the toxic
environment that I grew up in so Mark
was the first one I met Mark he was the
first person that did show me
hey there's another side to life let's
turn the page and look at how beautiful
it can be
and I saw the beauty in life and I
experienced Beauty in life
through mark
was my angel
he was my soul mate
and the greatest part of my life the
most important part of my life for many
years
and even now after his death
he still holds a special place in my in
my life
one of my dogs who I named Alfred I
named after Mark Mark was his middle
name was Alfred so when when when Mark
died I was all alone I had no pets I had
known nothing no one and I would spend
my entire days alone in my apartment
just crying
and I finally had a dream when Mark came
to me and my dream
he grabbed me he he took me by the hand
we were in this dark room it was all
pitch black
I could only see like my hands and my I
couldn't see anything else everything
was Pitch Black
so he Mark took me by the hand and then
he went like this showing me he said
like look at this there was a mirror on
the wall and he took me to that mirror
and he went like this to me on it with
his hand like look so I looked
and I was dressed in a blue
like a
[Music]
it looked like monks
Cape or something like that amongst a
tire it was it was it was a just a blue
uh uh outfit that I had and it was like
cobalt blue because that was my favorite
color
and
it was like as if the blue was
Illuminating the surrounding you can see
hints of blue because it was like
shining it was just there was light
radiating from the blue
and it was then that I thought okay
Mark wants me to look into the future
that was his way of saying look into the
future there's a future there for you
that's the message I got from Mark so I
immediately got on in my car and I drove
to the local SPCA in Houston and I was
going to be adopting a dog
because I felt a dog would be the
perfect
companionship for me
so
I was busy signing paperwork filling out
the paperwork to adopt this little dog
that I thought was really cute and I was
going to adopt when this young couple
walked into the building
at the SPCA and they walked into the
adoption side there's two different
sides of the building one is where you
drop off your pet
and for adoption you leave them there
and then the other side is where you
actually going to look for a pet to
adopt well I was on the adopting side of
the building so this couple approached
me and the girl was crying
and she looks so sad and I asked her I
said are you okay she goes do you like
him and so she looked down and she had a
little dog uh on the leash
it was a pup
and I said oh how cute he's so cute they
said can you please take him and I'm
like I said excuse me
aren't you I said aren't you here to
adopt this pet they said no they said we
can't keep him and we need I need I'm
trying to find someone to take him
because we don't want them to put him to
sleep she says please take him and she
was crying and crying and then I started
crying because I could feel like the
reasons why she was crying and it really
hurt her that that she was scared that
the dog could have been put under
and I said I looked at him and I said
come on Alfred let's go
as as soon as I said that he why just
tell he did his little hippity hop jump
that he does and to let it to let me
know he's happy and from that point on
his name was Alfred you know he just
knew it his name was Alfred so
um
and the reason I had to name him Alfred
is because
even though Mark before he died even
though he begged me he said
he says honey
if I ever die
I want you to meet someone
who who's going to be nice to you who's
going to take care of you and love you
the way that you need to be loved
he says I don't want you to be by
yourself I don't want you to be alone
and lonely he says promise me that
you'll meet someone promise me that
you'll
go out and find someone so I had to
promise him that I would but
I knew at the time that there's just no
way
so I've been single for the last 14
years since he'd passed away
um I haven't I tried dating somebody one
time and that went nowhere real fast
it's gonna be a special person with all
your body modifications right this
person what kind of reactions do you get
from
from people on the street
I guess
the reactions that I get from people on
the street about what
about my body modifications are pretty
much positive there is a there are a few
people that automatically think and
assume that I am the devil oh look at
she's they've got devil horns and I tell
them no they're not devil horns they're
Dragon horns the other D the dragon okay
not the devil
um
just so that everybody knows how I feel
about the devil the devil can suck my
you know I I don't I don't deal
with this whole devil I think
the whole devil thing is an actual
that I want nothing to do with
and I want don't want anyone to
associate me with the devil because I am
not the devil I am much bigger and much
better than the devil
so yeah did you ever do you ever regret
all the modifications you've done
you know Mark when I first started my
transformation I asked myself that very
question
like what what if I regret this on life
later on in life and I'm going to get
horns uh when I got my new horns that
changed how everybody treated me people
were starting to treat me like
um like I was someone to stay away from
uh because most people who looked at me
initially
uh in during the early parts of my
transformation most people thought that
I was the devil
and some people still think today that
I'm the devil and I've told people in
interviews that I've done I am not the
freaking devil quit calling me the devil
that's that's like putting me down you
know it's not
it doesn't make me feel good like oh
yippee I'm being called the devil no
because you know people aren't doing it
in a nice way they don't refer to me as
as as the angel of Light because that's
if you want to get right down to it that
is who the devil is he's the angel of
Light Lucifer that is his name Lucifer
it means angel of Light
so
in a way I could I you know my attitude
about people calling me the devil could
be this
okay
I'm the devil
aren't I beautiful
I'm the angel of Light do you know what
a big compliment you're giving me by
calling me the devil you are
complimenting me now I was God's chosen
angel
angel of Light Lucifer created by your
God
so think about what people need to think
about how they
want to put me down because I'm not an
idiot you know I I I can run circles
around some people who think that they
know it all know the challenge Legion
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
the most important lesson that I've
learned in my life
and this might seem
weird but
you know that Bible verse that says love
your enemies
[Music]
it's kind of along those lines
I understand
how and why people
some people
think that I'm the devil
when they see me that is the first thing
that comes to their mind
because
honestly
people are ignorant and I can't be mad
at people because of their ignorance
ignorance
is out there
and a lot of people only know that if
someone puts horns on their head like
myself
in their mind because of how they were
raised and what things they were taught
by their family
I am the devil
but like again like I said that's really
not
although it's being it's meant to put me
down
it's not a put down for me it's actually
you're putting me on a pedestal by
calling me the devil because you're
essentially calling me Lucifer the angel
of Light so how much more
beautiful can anyone want to be he was
the most beautiful angel that God made
so
you want to call me the devil keep
calling me the devil I'll own it why not
I'll just throw it in with the name
legion just another name that people
know me by
when I walk through here uh through
through the neighborhood I hear people
yelling at me devil devil Dragon Medusa
Dragon Lady
I'm like I'm no longer a lady I don't
want to be called a lady I remember from
the first interview that we did Mark uh
you and I together uh that some of the
comments on on on on YouTube uh in the
uh uh in in the interview some people
are just so
damned
ugly and nasty and hateful
the only thing that they could come up
with to comment on
about everything that I've shared in my
story
the only thing that they are going to
comment on
is something like that's no lady that's
a man that's now lady that's a man
so guess what y'all you're right I'm no
lady I am no one
oh you thought I was gonna say I'm a man
no I'm not a man
I'm not a woman I don't want to be
called a man or a woman I hate the fact
that humans have to categorize everybody
and nice little categories you know A to
Z accordion folders like no I don't want
to be a part of anyone's folder
that's why I call myself a genderless
dragon because I have no
gender in fact when I changed my name
legally and I went to DMV I was so happy
to let them know that my gender marker
has now been changed to non-binary
which means I'm not a man or a woman I'm
non-binary I don't
I don't um
approve of gender of the gender binary
and in fact I reject it I reject the
gender binary I think I I have a right
to be genderless
uh and that's what I how I see myself
as far as sexual activity
boring I am so bored you know people
with their sex
I just don't understand why humans are
so sexually
like active
everything has like it's almost like
everything is revolves around sex when
it comes to humans
well us reptiles we have different
things to worry about like I don't worry
about sex I haven't been with anyone in
over 10 years and I'm quite happy being
alone by myself
me myself and I and not letting my body
be uh tainted or be uh
um
put down or used in any way by someone
because they want to experience sex with
the Dragon Lady well too bad that ain't
happening because I don't even like sex
so
even if I
would say oh man I met someone really
hot and really cute
looks are Skin Deep Beauty is skin deep
in most cases people's outer beauty
doesn't match their inner heart because
they are beautiful outside but they're
Wicked and they're evil inside and
they're not nice people
and those kind of people I don't like
[Laughter]
no don't deal with dirty people
um all right
Legion thank you so much for sharing
your story you're welcome you're
fascinating as always thank you great
seeing you again likewise it's my
pleasure it's been such a pleasure
always a pleasure to talk to you Mark
and to be a part of your projects thank
you for the bottom of my heart I'm
humble and honored that uh to be here to
talk to you to share my story with you
and your followers excellent thank you
so much